I saw Jane two weeks ago at the rodeo  look at me do I look like a Korean we  may love our country but we want  something better for ourselves I'm gonna  be a rodeo queen this year I'm gonna win  that crown I think something might have  happened Ajay give me a call  all right about you J she has long brown  hair her back door was open  she's not a runaway no she's she's  missing do you know this woman you best  stop looking for your friend she's the  table if I see this girl hi Sara she's  still missing  do you see a avaricum Jane ready  please come strong like I say a bit of  Mines the desert it'll my ass all on you  up I got something that will help you  find Jane  [Music]  we lost aren't you there are two types  of people in this world those who are  lost and powerless King and those who  have found their place  you can be part of something the  American Dream has been tasted  nice  the American Dream has been taken away  from me  you  you